there are at least three main ways that
you could Define an ellipse
geometrically one is to say you take a
circle and you just stretch it out in
one dimension another is the classic two
thumb tacks and a piece of string
construction where you Loop a string
around two thumb tacks stuck into a
piece of paper and Pull It taut with a
pencil and then Trace around keeping the
string taut the whole time and yet
another way to define an ellipse is to
slice a cone with a plane at an angle an
angle that's smaller than the slope of
the cone itself why why on Earth should
these three definitions have anything to
do with each other I mean sure it kind
of makes sense that each should produce
some vaguely oval looking stretched out
Loop but why should the family of Curves
produced by these three totally
different methods be precisely the same
shapes